we have a vehicle into a structure with
destruction fire
they're going to remove the body from
the vehicle and possibly transport the
victim to a hospital
i think it's a miracle that she didn't
kill anyone anne's ref told us this
afternoon the actress was in quote
extreme critical condition adding she is
in a coma and has not regained
consciousness since shortly after the
accident
e.t has obtained footage from a second
ring camera which shows another angle of
ann's blue mini cooper barreling down
the street
and this is anne on a stretcher
according to neighbors she was screaming
at the time the l.a times says
authorities deemed her to be quote under
the influence and acting erratically
it's like a bomb going off
this morning e.t spoke to two neighbors
who were startled by the crash and ran
to help the car entered the house and
went all the way through the house it
took 59 firefighters 65 minutes to
extinguish the fire and remove anne from
her vehicle
in a podcast recorded three days before
the crash and was reportedly drinking
vodka and wine slurring her words and
joking about being rocked by a very bad
day it's just me up so i'm drinking some
vodka and wine
that episode has now been taken down but
two weeks before it was champagne i
swear to god my glass is jumping
ann who's well known for starring in a
remake of psycho and opposite harrison
ford in six days seven nights has been
open about her past mental health
challenges i wrote the book to give
closure to my life the actress has
talked about struggles before including
after splitting with ellen in her 2001
memoir call me crazy the stigma attached
to that relationship
was so
bad that i was fired and i did not work
in a studio picture for 10 years
i spoke with ann in 2020 after she
competed on dancing with the stars and
asked about reconnecting with the talk
show host so if ellen does call you
what do you say to her
wrong number
oh can i call you back i have
a shot
anne's rep tells e.t quote her family
and friends ask for your thoughts and
prayers and to respect her privacy
during this difficult time
you